classé difficile la langue française
vous trouvez pas c'est difficile
d'abord c'est illogique c'est
complètement illogique
par exemple chienne c'est le féminin de
chiens et ben traîne ça n'est pas le
féminin de train allez comprendre
et pourtant si vous dites à un coureur
cycliste est à la traîne
il vous répond je me voir suivre le
train c'est complètement une logique
c'est comme seine seine qui n'est pas le
féminin de st et pourtant maintenant
pour monter sur scène pour montrer ses
seins si si si à six mois on me l'a pas
encore demandé
non mais je vous préviendrai faut faire
une occasion de revenir par me l'a pas
demandé mais si on me le demandait
qu'est ce que je répondrais je ne suis
pas sain ils vont faire une scène
annoncée difficile la langue française
entonné essayé d'expliquer ça à
l'étranger
c'est un marin qui cherchent une
marraine déjà bon il fait des pieds et
des mains
il se démène mais comme il n'ya pas de
vesle ces efforts seront vains et en
voile un corps adlène j'ai pris
comprendra rien de très probant
surtout si c'est à l'étranger du nord du
nord de vervins où il ya de la verveine
et des frites et moi par exemple je
connais une fille quand on voit ses
cheveux d'ébène
tout le monde fait vous êtes déjà venu
vous on ne fait elle a un port de reine
à cause de sa chute de reins seulement
elle mange trop de pain elle grossit moi
ça me fait de la peine
alors je dis si tu veux encore faire du
gain mais une gaine annonçait difficile
à l'enfant c'est très difficile